hopes and prayers are running high in
bushagara Camp
these are just some of the half a
million people who fled fighting in
eastern Democratic Republic of Congo
they're surviving the best they can but
they're hoping this U.N security Council
delegation can bring an end to the
violence and they'll be able to go home
we are all listening hoping that clear
instructions claim messages will be sent
to Rwanda and to the M23 so that on
March 31st at the latest our territory
can be liberated and that these
thousands of disaster-stricken people
can begin to return to their places of
origin progressively this is our great
hope
the UN team has spent three days
assessing the security situation
M23 Rebels have been taking Villages and
towns and getting closer to the
provincial capital Goma
they're accused of massacring dozens of
civilians they carry Rwandan Army
equipment and are widely understood to
be backed by Rwanda
Kigali denies the allegations but on
Sunday the French ambassador to the UN
said there was no denying the connection
it is clear that Rwanda supports the M23
it is also clearly established that
there are incursions by the regular
Rwandan Army in north kivu and that this
too is unacceptable so this is one of
the subjects that must be discussed and
it must stop
a ceasefire between M23 and the
Congolese government was supposed to
take effect last week but collapsed
within hours
the way out of the crisis in this case
can only be political it can only be
through negotiation but in an emergency
security must be improved action must be
taken coercion must be used when
necessary particularly against groups
against the M23 and against others
M23 is just one of dozens of Rebel
groups operating in the region more than
50 people have been killed in three
separate attacks in recent days
local officials say the gunmen were with
the Allied Democratic forces an armed
group with origins in Uganda that's
pledged allegiance to isil
each attack sends more people from their
homes carrying what they can into
overcrowded camps
and each time the pressure mounts on the
U.N to put an end to the violence
and while this visit may have raised the
hopes of some achieving peace in eastern
DRC continues to be a Monumental task
Alexandra Byers Al Jazeera